Democrats have launched a blitz accusing
the Trump administration of separating
children from their parents and housing
them and literally concentration camps
along the border leftist politicians
from senators to Hillary Clinton took
their best shots it is unacceptable in
my mind I think in the minds and hearts
of any American that someone can justify
a policy of deliberate harm to children
as a way to gain legislative leverage in
fact what he's doing is holding these
kids and their parents hostage to a
whole set of other immigration issues
separating families is not mandated by
law at all that is an outright lie and
it's incumbent on all of us
journalists and citizens alike to call
it just that okay she should know
something about lying right with
administration with emotions running
this hot so is this a PR battle the
administration can win let's discuss all
this with a head of the Justice
Department we are pleased to welcome
Attorney General Jeff Sessions first
time on the Ingraham angle General
Sessions thank you so much for being
with us there's a lot to get you tonight
but you heard what mrs. Clinton said
that this is a lie this is not caused by
the Obama administration this doesn't
have to be done the president could pick
up the phone tonight and stop this
policy of separating children from their
parents what's the real truth there
General Sessions well I guess what she's
saying is the president could just issue
a directive that everybody that enters
the country unlawfully be released into
the country and never be apprehended or
stopped or prosecuted for the illegal
entry we we have watched what happened
with the Obama policies and over the
years we went from 15,000 illegal
entries to 75,000 this is a huge
loophole in our system that's attracting
more and more people as more and more
people understand that under previous
policies if they were entered the
country unlawfully nothing never
happened we're doing the right thing
we're taking care of these children they
are not being
abused the Health and Human Services
holds them in good conditions they work
hard at it
we spent a billion dollars last year
Health and Human Services did in taking
care of children who've entered the
country unlawfully and lorem one more
thing the vast majority of those
children still tend to be the
unaccompanied minors but we've had a big
surge in families bringing children or
some adults bringing children with them
one of the shelters not too far from the
border has 90% of the kids where
unaccompanied minors 10% were separated
from their families just so my viewers
understand this General Sessions what
happens when it family unit you see them
all in the bridges which I think it's
just absurd that they're they just stand
the bridges near the ports of entry near
San Diego now when they get processed in
and it's slow they get processed in and
it's a woman says this is my child or
two children then what happens are they
separated if they claim asylum say I
want to claim asylum what happens to the
mother and the children at that point if
the end of the country at a port of
entry and there are many of those along
the border they are not violating the
law the mother or father in that
circumstance would not be prosecuted and
the families are stay together they can
there presumably they're claiming an
asylum and that's they would not be
prosecuted and not be separated but if
they go out in the desert they cross a
fence or barrier our officers have to
identify them follow them apprehend them
they're violating the law and they need
to be prosecuted for that they simply
cannot condone that kind of activity we
want to end this process of children
being brought across dangerous territory
placing those children at risk if they
want to claim asylum let them go through
the port of entry that's the way it
should be done yeah I think most people
aren't understanding this I think most
people think that if you come even
through one of the what 25 ports of
entry you could you have your family
separated that's not how it's working
it's a rare circumstance when I think
the Border Patrol people know
that's this person is not related to
this other person and they can figure it
out pretty quickly in those
circumstances I just think it was
important to have the people understand
that this is how your opponent's general
sessions are demagoguing this issue
let's listen I've walked down that
railroad siding where the families were
separated and that's why I used that
picture now look I I know we're not Nazi
Germany all right but there is a
commonality there this is the United
States of Germany and the United States
of America it isn't Nazi Germany and
there's a difference and we don't take
children from their parents until now
Nazi Germany concentration camps human
rights violations Laura Bush's wade in
Michelle Obama Rosalynn Carter got all
the first lady's gone back to Eleanor
Roosevelt she's apparently weighed in as
well
general sessions what's going on here
well it's a real exaggeration of course
in Nazi Germany they were keeping the
Jews from leaving the country but this
is a serious matter we need to think it
through be rational and thoughtful about
it we want to allow asylum for people
who qualify for it but people who want
economic migration for their personal
financial benefit and what they think is
their family's benefit is not a Nessus
for a claim of asylum but they can make
that our claim we will process it and
review the situation and make a decision
those children if the parent brings them
across the border in an unlawful area
and the parent is deported they will
take the children home with them that is
true if the parent claims of settlement
is allowed to stay here then the
children stay here also in bed captain
Health and Human Services custody
yeah General Sessions is this policy in
part used as a deterrent is it are you
trying to deter people from bringing
children or minors across this dangerous
journey is that part of what the
separation is a
fundamentally we are enforcing the law
if you break into the country in an
unlined is it a deterrent sir
well it's a deterrent I see that the
fact that no one was being prosecuted
for this as they factor in a five-fold
increase in four years in this kind of
illegal immigration
so yes hopefully people will get the
message and come through the border at
the port of entry and not break break
across the bar unlawfully and let me get
your quick thoughts sir if you would on
this looming showdown with congressional
investigators are trying to get those
documents as you know from your
department and trey gowdy oversight
chair he said yesterday that officials
will be held in contempt of Congress if
the DOJ and FBI do not comply with the
subpoenas what are your thoughts on that
well we've gone a long way in dealing
with that and the FBI's worked hard on
it I think an agreement was signed with
mr. Gowdy and chairman Goodlatte both
chairmen to have 12 of their staffers at
the Department of Justice at the FBI
looking at these records and so I think
that's moving along pretty well
hopefully there general sessions that I
hate to interrupt there out of patience
they feel like they've been asking for
these documents some of these documents
end up showing up with the IG report
that the Congress asked for months and
months and months ago so you can't mean
you were in Congress you know what it's
like to try to do oversight it's really
frustrating and you Rosenstein in
contempt I mean they're gonna hold them
in contempt of Congress then what well
we are going we have a responsibility to
respond to Congress we intend to be
responsive to Congress if we're running
behind in production we'll take efforts
to step it up and the we have a
responsibility to produce the documents
that are properly disclosable and we
intend to do so
that's my direction to the department
senators senator sessions attorney
general sessions are just one more
question are you involved at all in in
discussions about a possible recusal of
rod Rosenstein from overseeing muller
given the fact that he did sign one of
those FISA warrants it's a big you know
it's a big controversy in this case I am
not involved in that he is the acting
Attorney General for that matter and he
has to make his own decision as I had to
make my decision got it got at General
Sessions thank you so much for spending
time with us tonight
such important issues at the border we
really appreciate it